okay I'm back Ben is back I was gone for
three months and as soon as the police
were hot on my trail I came back and
here for another three months and then
they'll probably figure it out you know
how they're it takes about three months
so with this is mastering the middle
game so I have to dumb the lecture down
a little bit because normally I teach
about Grandmaster in the middle game and
in fact speaking of grandmasters
we are going to discuss positions from
the US Championship which is ongoing as
far as I'm concerned as far as you're
concerned Fabiano's already won the
tournament so you're very confused over
there and Wesley so came in second yeah
a disappointing finish for a car oh
that's too bad
okay so let's talk about we're actually
after around five now so we actually
don't know what's going to happen the
next six rounds but but you at home do
all right cool
so the first game we're going to look at
was from round one round one was
actually the best round for the big
three Chrysler car Awana and GM no wait
a minute I'm sorry GM Nakamura Toyota
wait I'm getting confused oh yeah
it's Wesley so Fabiano car Awana and
Hikaru Nakamura they all won very nicely
in round one and there was very good
middle games in a lot of games of the US
Championship first time we're going to
look at his car Awana versus a Cobian
VAR not having his best tournament ever
or is he oh snap
okay so in this position var obviously
Ian counted his bishop and this is a
very strange-looking position because
blacks not castles yet it's not clear
where he's going to castle and White's
Castle queenside however White's made a
lot of pawn moves on the Kings side and
that's a shoe or white can get more
space and so Fabiana played f4 and
problem with blacks position is White's
going to have basically a better
position all three parts of the board
the center Queen side and Kings side and
the reason of our plate is very
got to this position was he thought he
could play Queen h4 here attacking the
knight on h3 and it doesn't look good
for the night but actually there's some
there's some tactics here so he played
Bishop to d6 and after f5 why had an
obvious advantage but let's have a look
at Queen h4 which is what var was
intending to play wouldn't this happen
the idea is the knight on h3 is attacked
if the knight moves away Knight takes f4
attacking the Queen and attacking the
rook on h1 excuse me so problem is y can
get very aggressive with the move Knight
g5 and now to refute 9 g5 since the
Queen is virtually trapped we play the
obvious move Knight takes f4 can anyone
in the audience see what white does here
and this is the part that var missed he
thought I've won upon I'm attacking the
Queen I'm attacking the rook I'm
attacking the knight it all sounds good
until you see White's next to move any
one you at home now you're wrong at home
- no nothing we had nothing I'll talk in
a badge ok so we can throw in this check
with Bishop to b5 and this is a problem
because black can't do any of the stuff
that I said because he's in check and
the problem with c6 as it blocks the
bishop so we've got rid of one of our
threats and now y can play Queen e5
defending his Knight attacking this
Knight and threatening to come into c7
and I'll give you a sample variation
because you deserve it you're paying
customers let's trade some pieces let's
take a free rook taking free tricks is
good right and then let's get checkmated
ok blacks King not so good ok sort of
exposed so if we go back it turns out
after 9 g5 and vari analyzes for a long
time in his head he concluded white was
winning which was what Fabiano concluded
and unfortunately for her that's correct
Queen h4 9 g5 gives white close to
winning advantage well if you can't play
Queen
h4 White's going to advance on the King
side attack e6 and blacks King is is
misplaced
so sometimes strategically things are
working out but they don't work
tactically so Bishop to d6 f5 attacking
the e6 pawn var played Queen e7 this
should take g7 winning a pawn and this
goes back to b2 and well at my level and
lower being a pawn up is good but it's
not really a guarantee of a victory but
at the top level you know the top 10 top
20 players in the world it's rare to be
a pawn ahead for nothing and so when you
get the chance their technique is
impeccable they almost always win and
here finally very late into the game var
castled but I wouldn't say var has any
compensation for the pawn he's just down
upon and unfortunately that's the side
of the board he lost on the pawn the
side of the board where he had upon less
okay rook f1 getting the rook off of the
diagonal of the bishop and obviously
it's a good square for the rook rook EA
defending e6 f6 the pawn is defended by
the bishop and the rook so we can't
capture it and white just has a big
space advantage of the Kings side Plus
White has an extra pawn M Wow it wasn't
really great middle game-planning
it was very good planning followed by
good analysis he knew that Queen h4
didn't work for black that's what black
was counting on and as a result blacks
game went downhill very quickly and we
won't look too long into the end of the
game where basically white was a pawn up
and eventually just crashed through
could have crashed through earlier but
he was playing it safe because black
doesn't really have any counter play
here and that plant in f6 is really
annoying black really is passive in this
position and well basically have to
avoid time trouble Knight takes f7 what
white could have actually sacrificed on
f7 or East six several times but now it
was really obvious because after Queen
takes f7 white plays rook up to g7
getting his piece back when it was an
actual piece sac and y could play f7 and
rook g8 it was also winning but well
it's not a PC
now now we're just cleaning up and
blacks King is very exposed and white is
still up to pawns and the game ended
while var would normally resign it's
hard to resign when you have no time on
your clock you don't have time to resign
okay
and when they got to a position where
there was nothing else to do because b7
has attacked too many times finally
black gave up so that was a great middle
game from Fabiano who won upon on the
Kings side advanced his King side pawns
and eventually crashed through on the
Kings side with the move Knight takes f7
his plenum f6 was a really nice pawn
that anchored his rook on g7 ok now I've
been away for months I don't know how to
get to the next game so I get I guess
the lecture is over now figure out
something ok we'll get rid of this we'll
go here
we'll go to this other game alright
there we go now this was also from round
1 and I was going to say this is
probably the biggest crush calm skiis
ever head of the US Championship except
later in the tournament in a position
that was wow equal or slightly worse
maybe he made a terrible blunder lost to
Geoffrey Jean this game wasn't a one
move blunder this was a real crush of
one of conky's favorite openings the the
Brier variation of the real Lopez okay
now this position looks somewhat equal
probably most of us would prefer to have
white because white has these nice two
Center pawns here and blacks pawn is a
little back and that this shabam b7 is
somewhat blockaded as well on the other
hand what does y do about it it's not
easy to break through well in a lot of
reuleaux PES is white breaks throughout
a flank either on the Kings side of the
Queen side since they've traded pawns
and rooks on the Queen side and blacks
queen is offsides it's time to attack
the King and he played Knight h4 and
well White's going to try to put a
knight on f5 put a queen on f3 and start
attacking the black King Queen g8 was
played a move that I agree with getting
the Queen back into defense and Kamsky
has been known throughout his career
of having worse positions defending
defending and then when his opponent
goes a little too far
Chomsky counter-attacks and wins Wesley
played queen c1 attacking the pawn on h6
and now gotta made the losing move he
made sort of the obvious move of
defending the pawn but that allows a
piece sacrifice that crashes through
instead he should be very concerned
about these Knights and play Knight to H
7 which gives a discovered attack on the
knight on h4 and after the game Wesley
said yeah 9 8 7 I sort of expected that
I was going to move my knight back to f3
and probably Black has to play h5 to
save his pawn and I thought white was a
little better maybe some move like rook
to d1 and try to open the D file and you
know play against black making a lot of
weakened and Kings side pawn moves than
the bishop on b7 sort of block and again
White has more Center pawns on the 4th
rank so lights a little bit better and
that's what blacks should have done and
probably if Khan ski was in good form
you would have played nine eight seven
instead his sense of danger eluded him
today and for another round and he
played them of King h7 which defends the
pawn on h6 and unfortunately the
computers were screaming we had to turn
the volume down that White has a winning
sacrifice and a winning attack and those
aren't the kinds of moves that Wesley so
misses Wesley's very accurate and plays
very aggressively he played one of his
knights to f5 sacrificing a piece and
the problem is we have what's called
long-term compensation we don't have to
win right away we can say well I'm going
to build up my attack and my Knights on
f5 the whole game your pieces are all
terrible and I have many threats I'm
threatening to take on h6 I'm
threatening to take on d6 which by the
way Forks everything and I'm also
threatening to move my rook up to the
3rd rank and later in the game he could
play Queens u1 and get his Queen over to
the Kings side it's not really clear
what black does black and say yeah I'm
up a piece ok and after the game
I think Wesley was talking about the
move rookie six which said it surprised
him although I think the engines like
that move he was expecting something
like 9 g8 defending his pawn on h6 and
then 9 takes d6 and obviously White has
tremendous compensation for a piece
probably he's going to win an exchange
back and simply be equal or up material
with black having a terrible King
White's King on the other hand is very
safe okay
so gotta played rookie six Bishop takes
h6 obviously we can't trade that's a
very simple checkmate Queen takes h6 and
checkmate
okay so black followed my rule of never
trading and play 98 defending his Bishop
again white doesn't have an immediate
win watches builds the pressure has two
pawns for peace makes a lot of threats
and the two reasons White's winning
white has this beautiful night on f5 and
white also has the bishop opposite the
King on this diagonal which allows him
often to play the move d5 and if we
trade on d5 it opens up this diagonal
for the white bishop so white has a lot
of possible threats again white doesn't
want to trade pieces white wants to keep
the attack going so he plays Bishop to
g5 and here god I made his position even
worse which is actually very hard to see
beforehand he played sort of the obvious
move Bishop f6 we want to trade pieces
unfortunately after takes it's very hard
to take back there's four ways to do it
and they're all bad okay normally with
blacks moving pieces towards his own
King that would be awesome but he has
some issues one issue is he doesn't want
to allow Queen h6 or Queen g5 so for
example if you take with either Knight
then you just get checkmated okay as we
saw before okay so obviously we have to
take with the rook or the Queen gotta
ended up taking with the Queen which
well they're both really bad I'm not
sure which is worse I think taking with
the Queen is a little worse than with
the rook
in the end they're both losing after
rook takes White has two good plans and
actually he could play both of them he's
going to play Queen d1 and Queen h5
check he's going to play rook e3 and
rook g3 and with the Queen rook and
Knight attacking the black king and the
fact that this bishop on b7 is out of
play it's a pretty safe attack for white
the extra piece is meaningless for black
because his pieces don't do anything
okay got to play Queen chase f6 and that
was based on a miscalculation he saw
that his rook would be trapped after the
move d5 the rook has nowhere to go
and he played rookie 7 thinking he was
going to give back in exchange since
he's already up a piece of course if we
trade on d5 and just try to win a pawn
now every legal Knight move is a
discovered check and many of them are
good probably the best is 93 check or 97
taking the bishop on d5 and then whites
just winning okay so got a played rookie
7 obviously expecting Knight takes rook
Queen takes Knight and he would have two
knights for a rock why would have an
extra pawn or two but it would be hard
to checkmate black because the pieces
are gone and well if my student may
Larson or my good friend Patrick wolf
former US Champion are watching this
game well here white played the favorite
move of either player they both like
this move and I'm sure they would have
found it and I was funny when this move
was played Gatto was shaking his head
and Hikaru was standing behind goddess
shaking his head so they was a
repetition of head shaking and the move
that was played has the idea of forcing
the Queen off of the rook so we can take
the rook for free that's better than
taking the rook and losing your knight
so what move did white play which
attempted to force the black Queen away
from the rook does anybody remember or
can they figure it out g4 very good and
if you know Patrick wolf or Matt Larsen
that's their favorite move g4 and
White's going to play g5 next move
and I don't legally see how these four
pieces can defend the black rook and the
black rug can't move so I'm going to
play g5 that you're going to move your
queen and I'm going to take your hook
for free and then not only is white
trying to checkmate black white is ahead
material and obviously when God I took
with the Queen he didn't see the move g4
otherwise he would have taken with the
rook although well usually when your
game is really bad you need to be a
super computer to defend perfectly every
move and just have a worse loss position
as opposed to losing right away now god
of course over the last 20 years has
been that kind of player where when he
is worse he defends perfectly and
eventually hopes his opponent falters
this game neither one happened he made a
couple of defensive mistakes and Wesley
did not falter a really brutal win in
round 1 in fact for those of you who
remember last year when Wesley was
forfeited on move six against Varro
Cobian he actually won every game
afterwards he won the last two rounds of
the US Championship and he won the first
two rounds of this US Championship and
beating gada twice he begot it with the
black pieces last year after the forfeit
and he begot it with the white pieces
this year so Wesley so he's not number
10 for no reason and as of today today
for me not for you Wesley is only three
points lower weight of the Nakamura so
maybe by the time you watch this I don't
know who will be higher rated probably
not the same rating okay we'll get rid
of this for confusion okay now we'll
look at another one of the very
interesting middle games this was
actually too complicated for me I had my
engines running
I had grandmasters helping me but I just
decided to sit in the corner ball myself
up in a fetal position because I could
understand this game so this is a French
defense it's a favorite variation of
Conrad halt who has black in these
positions all the time it looks like
White's advancing on the Kings side and
blacks advancing on the Queen side it
looks like that because that's what's
happening okay unfortunately for black
white has more space
y can just chill out and eventually
advance or he can wait for black to
advance to his detriment okay
and white has a very long complicated
sequence of moves which will eventually
break through on the Kings side and that
is to play h5 and in fact black white
played Bishop d2 but let me show you
what White's plan is and we will make
any moves for black because I wouldn't
be fair
why wants to play h5 at some point then
retreat is Knight and black moves back
and forth I'm just showing White's plan
white eventually plays f4 takes with a
knight and black moves back and forth
now why can put his rooks on the F file
and this Queens not very happy there's
going to be a discovered attack against
that Queen and another plan for white is
simply to break through on the Kings
side by pushing the pawns
now Shanklin realized in the long run
that would be a very good plan for white
okay so so let's go back to the real
position okay and Fabiano play to move
here he actually wasn't happy with later
he played the move Bishop d2 okay and b4
was played which was somewhat surprising
because you would think the point of
Bishop d2 was was to stop that but
actually the bishop you know can dance
at two weddings it's not going over here
and defending the knight on f4 if the
bishop ever goes to a5 or B for c3 black
is going to play Queen takes nine track
okay now it's funny is Shanklin broke
through on the Queen side the normal
plan and because of that
Fabiana switched his pieces over the
Queen side and took over that's the
problem with playing the number two
player in the world sometimes when
they're winning on one side they decide
on the win another side to that was a
Karpov trademark now here white has more
space on the Kings side white has more
space of the center Black's winning on
the Queen side so Fabiano just shifts
over there
problem is even though black has a lot
of pawns around the Queen side it seems
like his pieces are on the Kings side so
he's not really helping his pawns along
okay so Fabiano traded the pawns getting
rid of his weak a pawn opening up his
rook and then played rook to be one sort
of abandoning his King side attack
because he wants to win on all three
parts of the board
and knight c6 defending the pawn queen
III the Queen defends the C pawn the D
pawn end the night the Queen's much
better on e3 b3 getting a passed pawn
and now as we've seen a lot of French
defenses the Bishop on the dark squares
likes to go to a3 and go on this nice
long diagonal well that wasn't happening
for a long time because white hat upon
on a3 and White's Bishop was on e3 but
that's all changed and so Fabiana found
the very nice maneuver Bishop c1 he's
going to play Bishop a3 and the rook on
f8 is trapped well we might not even
want the rook on FA we want to play
Bishop to d6 and our Bishop is fantastic
okay so this is a really nice one over
by Fabiano Bishop to d7 defending the
rook we could take the pawn on c2 but
we're going to lose that pawn that's
that's not going to be defended and why
can trade rooks on b8 for example and
then play the move Bishop a3 and I don't
know what you're going to do about this
so this is going to be a winning
position for white and if Black gets any
ideas of defending his C pawn
unfortunately his bishops hanging so the
truth hurts okay and that Bishop is
going to get to a really good square
okay so Bishop d7 connecting the rooks
Bishop a3 he takes the pawn on c2 and
Fabiano plays rook c1 so Fabiano is
going to get his Bishop to a really nice
square he's going to infiltrate with his
rook this pawn is going to fall and
White's going to be winning on all three
sides of the board but white hasn't won
the game yet now Sam can hunker down and
defend and say there's nothing for you
to do you can't win and that's exactly
what he did he tried to just defend and
say well what are you going to take how
are you going to meet me what are you
going to do even though White has an
advantage on all three sides of the
board what exactly does he do okay and
that's why we have world-class technique
here and it was a very nice maneuver
when he infiltrated with his pieces on
the Queen side there was still no easy
way to win for white just repeating
moves
and putting trying to put black in zoogs
one but not easy okay nine h3 is a good
move and g5 just getting more more of
the position Sam locks it up now White
has even more space black really has
nothing to do and eventually there's a
lot of good squares you're on the Queen
side for the White Knight the Knights
not he done enough for anymore and by
playing the move g5 black camp pushes
pawns on the Kings side so White's king
is perfectly safe so white has another
piece into the attack and gets his King
safe to the queen side before doing
anything Knight d5 Knight a7 and finally
he's in trouble this position if he
plays the move Bishop takes Knight which
looks like it wins a piece black plays
rook b8 and gets his piece back olive
White's pieces are hanging and if he
plays the move Queen takes Knight
instead of 1987 then the knight on d5 is
hanging so very good defense by Sam but
Fabiana didn't fall for any of that
Fabiano just played Knight a7 and said
okay your rooks attacked your Knights
attacked I finally crashed through and
it took a long time but black didn't
have any counter plight and after Knight
a7 Sam resigned because he's going to
lose while at least a piece if not more
than white crashed through now earlier
in the game there was a very funny point
where black had counter play with a very
unusual move in this position when he
played King III
there was the crazy move Queen f7
sacrificing the rook and in fact Fabiano
said he saw this move right after he
played King III
and he was just going to trade Queens
and try to crash through later the idea
is after Queen takes rook black plays
Queen f5 threatening Queen d3 check with
a perpetual check and these white pieces
are not very well placed to stop queen
d3 in the Queen
tration so that was Sam's last chance to
defend although it's very hard to see a
move which intentionally gives away a
ruck when you're hoping for perpetual
check which it turns out would have been
the case if you had taken the rook very
similar we're doing live comments here
Alejandro and I reminded me of the
Kasparov D blue match where because Bart
resigned in a draw in position
he could have sacrificed a piece and
tried for perpetual thinking while the
computer wouldn't let me do that the
computer is winning we're petrol but in
fact it had and this was a conundrum
that seconds were in should they tell
him about it and he would be furious
that he resigned in a drum position or
should they not tell him about until
after the match but what if he reads
about on the internet what if somebody
in the street tells him like then he's
like what do you mean why did you guys
tell me I was drawing so yeah here Queen
f7 gave some chances probably black
would lose in the long run with a Queen
trade since he really can't move
anything so it's very difficult
defensive task what your opponent's
putting pressure on you there's no
direct threat but you're very passive
and that's the trademark of Fabiano and
other strong players who like to play
that way our Karpov and calm ski owner
shook a lot of top players like to
squeeze their opponents okay now this is
a really interesting endgame
I'm sorry middle game because the
players try to make it interesting
white sacrificed a pawn White has tons
of compensation first of all he's
putting tremendous pressure on the pin
here with the king and queen he has the
two bishops black's extra pawn is pretty
weak i mean you could argue it's good
white doesn't have a deep pawn because
his bishop is strong his rook can go on
the half-open file
and black has trouble getting his King
safe so white has great compensation for
a pawn and that's because the players
chose to play that way Lenderman decided
I'm going to win a pawn I'm going to
defend and hopefully my extra pawn will
tell in the end and ownership slam with
my two bishops and attack I can crash
through okay he played Bishop c3 and now
sort of surprising move
I mean you'd think black wants to play
nine g7 that's why he played his Bishop
to f6 but instead he ran to safety with
King FA he's going to put his King on g7
and say look I'm a pawn up so I'm going
to win eventually you don't have any
attack castles King g7 and now very
strong move one I always advise against
that's why I'm at play in the
championship anymore f3 and the idea
behind f3 is it's going to open a
white's rook up and put tremendous
pressure on blacks position and often
when your opponent has a pawn on e4 and
you play f3 getting rid of it you get
rid of a lot of blacks advantages well
now blacks in a lot of trouble and the
computer says black is fine basically
because the computer is crazy it plays
perfect for both sides and eventually
says black is ok if you're a human here
you really want to have white the extra
pawn doesn't matter right now
your King is safer you have two bishops
you have an initiative and the rook on
h8 is trapped the other book is in the
corner the knight hasn't been developed
yet you're really happy if you're white
here the extra pawn doesn't bother you
ok Knight takes d4 which gives away the
queen but threatens this Queen White
doesn't want to trade all the pieces he
takes with a pawn and now he's
threatening the Queen the Queen moves
away we open up the F file obviously and
now they move rook e1 more if you will
be proud of this move I don't think it's
the computers first choice but I like it
because it takes White's only in active
piece and gives them a threat and this
position Alejandra and I were like wow
this game is good end pretty soon and
White's really crashing through in
crushing black and the engines like Oh
equal and we're like equal and the
engine wants to play the move a six here
which is a very strange move for a human
forcing whites and make more threats
okay so if I was black I would never
consider the move a6 because it forces
my opponent's Bishop to a better Square
and somehow the computer defends
everything and says black is okay again
there's a big difference between
computer and human
us when a computer can play perfectly
for one side and find moves that aren't
obvious and say that it's equal and a
human can do that like we know that why
it's going to win here because even if
white plays substandard moves he's still
gonna have a great attack and black has
to defend perfectly okay but rook c8
getting the rook to an open file
sort of like what ownership does just
did but now on this show gets his pawn
back and not only is the material
equalize now now he's ready to continue
attacking on the F file and now now
black has just lost rook c7 defending
the f7 pawn Bishop to b4 Bishop takes d4
check is a terrible move which ends the
game quickly black wants to get symmetry
off for his suffering but he's opening
up the F file for whites rook the King
moves to safety and now we were doing
some analysis of the game wondering how
white can win
we agreed that white would play exactly
what he did but the computer found that
incredibly beautiful win here which none
of us would have thought of does anybody
remember you guys remember every game of
the tournament you at home no there we
go
there's somebody who's following the
tournament rook to e6 and I was like
wait rook to you 6 what's going on well
the obvious idea is if you take the
bishop bishop f8 check wins the Queen so
that's good for white and the less
obvious idea is if you take the rook
then Bishop f8 always play Bishop FA
checkmate checkmate is good because you
win and obviously you could take with
the Queen and lead to the same checkmate
and ownership said he looked at rookie
six but not in this position he saw
these ideas with Bishop f8 but it didn't
occur to him here well the problem is if
you can take the rook and you can't take
the bishop where does your Queen go yeah
good answer
so rookie six was the computer move I
didn't think he was going to play that I
thought he would play exactly what he
played rugby for and Bishop c3 and
there's a funny variation here he did
take back immediately he could take on
f7 either way but after taking back
black can't defend f7 the queen is
attacked and no Queen move can safely
defend f7 so obviously white is just
winning and now White's technique was
always should say a little unusual he
decided to win an easily winning endgame
most of us would try to punish that King
on h6 but owners look likes the endgame
so Queen f8 check not something I would
have done and he's like I have a winning
endgame you're your rook and Knight er
can't move no good and he played King g7
and he's like well you could move here
Knight but I'll be too passed pawns up
so that's fine and eventually but rook
have seven instead of taking the pawn
again stopping black from moving his
pieces and it was an easily winning
endgame white didn't really have any
problems since black can't move anything
nice repetition and okay hopeless
endgame for black white has an extra
pawn now white has two extra pawns if
black had done something about his pawn
on h7 white would have played King d4
and black can't do anything so he
stopped king g4 but he gave another pawn
to do it and this is absolutely no
problem for y two extra pawns and
eventually lunderman resigned we were
sort of half joking during the game you
know with ownership try to trade Queens
go into an endgame that he did so he
likes end games what are you gonna do
okay and last but not least the game of
the tournament thus far maybe they'll be
better games after this videos made
between Cara Juana and Nakamura in fact
it was the only decisive game of the
round for the championship the other
games were drawn so they could watch
this game now of course many of us were
expecting a Berlin or a Petrov or
something where blacks trying to
equalize but Nakamura had less points
than Cara Juana and thought it was time
to win he had drawn comps key with the
black pieces and with white he got
nothing against Raksha Chandra very
surprising result
so Nakamura having half a point less
than Fabiana decided to play for a win
with black very dangerous idea and he
played the night off Sicilian with an
early age five
to paraphrase Sam Shanklin I'm not
paraphrasing
he said that's garbage kh5 Sam Shanklin
never one to mince words okay and well
Hikaru decided his position might be
okay
but castling kingside with the pot mh5
is a little dicey so you decided to
Castle queenside also dicey and he
played the move gg6 making his kingside
solid and then Castle queenside
surprising many of us now
Black has a couple of good continuation
zv5 or f5 and the engine actually
prefers 'if I've actually it's pretty
funny
in chess sometimes it's not what you do
it's what you don't do and here you
might think black Castle queenside
that's terrible he'll get checkmated
well maybe the other problem with
castling queenside any opening is you're
weakening your f7 pawn and when you
Castle kingside you're not weakening
anything we Castle queenside f7 is never
protected I'll let you do it
artificially rook F a rook aged seven
Bishop ei those are strange moves okay
and so both moves that white made have
the intention of attacking f7 Fabiano
plate f5 which is sort of a normal kind
of move with the bishop on b3 computer
even prefers a five and the main idea is
if your Knight moves away I'm going to
play Knight e4 with tempo and if you
trade pawns first I'm going to get an
active rook on the seventh rank and when
applied so that's also quite good for
white Fabiano chose f5 and after a five
attacking the knight retreated his a
knight and now F seven is attacked and
I'm going to attack it again and also of
great importance is now that Black has
played a five his pawns no longer on e6
the d5 square is very weak White has
access to the d5 square that he didn't
have before and that's actually going to
be key later okay so Nakamura took a
pawn and White has many good
continuations there's a couple of points
to take but instead fabi played Knight
to g5 he wants to take upon
by taking a rook and now he's unleashed
another attack on the f5 pawn so that's
a lot of pawns getting attacked now
nakamura correctly sacrificed the
exchange with that for giving himself a
nice pawn chain and also maybe he'll
play Bishop g4 and skewer the Queen and
rook and to me this was the nicest move
of the game and I'm sure Jennifer show
how do you liked it it was a rover or a
rook lifts
he played rook to d3 this avoids the
Bishop g4 skewer and when this Knight
moves probably to d5 Rick c3 is going to
be a very serious threat so I like to
move rook d3 Ally it gets the rook out
of the way of this bishop and it starts
attacking King b8 getting off of this
file Knight f7 Hikaru played for the
attack h4 and after Queen f2 computer
says black is still maybe okay and very
interesting move that wasn't played that
Fabiano showed us here in the analysis
room was the move d5 okay the top
players are always looking for counter
play for their opponents the idea is we
want to take with a bishop and play the
moves Knight h5 to g3 and start a mating
attack for example let's trade Queens
play Knight takes d5 looks good for
white and now that move Knight h5
suddenly 9 g3 is a very serious threat
very serious okay and then if you take
with a pawn you actually get checkmated
so we can play a stupid move I'm good at
that 9 g3 check checkmate
ok and Fabiano saw that kind of counter
play that was a bit worried about it and
he said after d5 I was going to do this
and it's complicated but instead Hikaru
made quite a bad move Queen before and
this was based on a miscalculation and
he just said he wasn't calculating well
that day so play the number two player
in the world you have the black pieces
you're not playing well easy to lose and
we the computer was explaining this
really strong move that we didn't get
right away and Fabi said this is where
he saw it played 9 to d5 sort of the
obvious move because it's a
threatens everything black is forced to
trade now White's going to play rugby
three winning immediately the only
obvious reason to play Queen before is
now you can play Bishop a4 stopping
rugby three and winning a pawn and well
this looks like black has a pawn for the
exchange the b2 pawn is hanging black
has more space on the Kings side
unfortunately the move rook a3 is
incredibly crushing this is actually
better than Rick a1 because of the
threat of c3 and while the bishop on a4
is actually going to be trapped and you
can't move the bishop because rook B 3
is going to be crushing for example if I
go here we just trade bishops and Rick
b3 wins your queen it's funny the way
hikaru play King ba to get off of this
Queen c5 and then you play Queen before
with this King MBA and it's the same
thing and if the bishop goes all the way
back for example rugby 3 is again
crushing there's no defense to the
attack on the B file in fact this
position the computer was saying Bishop
c8 was the best move that that wasn't
the point of Queen before but it sees
that it's going to get check mated so it
plays some move that's obviously losing
ok now
well now the engines were saying plus 3
plus 4 plus 5 which means it's all over
hikaru tried for counter play h3 but
while his bishop needs to be defended in
fact one of the main lines of the
computer plays Bishop to DA c3 Queen b6
trading Queens and losing the bishop but
you don't get checkmated see and those
are variations humans just don't look at
because we don't go into rook down in
games we try to do something else but
when that's the best variation for black
that's when the inept the analysts know
that it's a losing position ok so he
played h3 getting counter play c3 Queen
b5 defending the Bishop b3 the bishop is
trapped and obviously if white had
played rook to aim 1 instead of rook to
a3 his rook on d3 would be hanging now
it's very important to play rook a 3
instead of rook a 1 something that
Fabiano noticed right after Queen before
in fact I said to knock excuse me I said
to Alejandra Ramirez my co-commentator
do you think Fabi will find rook a 3 and
he said he's 2800 he has to okay
otherwise to take his rating away it was
funny a few days ago one of our local
chess guys year members said wow these
guys play really good I said yeah that's
why would you invite him here okay
guys are playing great well yeah they
play great okay so Bishop h4 getting
some counter play pawn takes the bishop
on a4 obviously if you take the Queen
and I take your queen you're down a rook
in the end game so he keeps his Queen g3
and this basically kills the rook on h8
nakamora resigned here you could take
the pawn and you could win the pawn but
this King is actually sheltered quite
nicely by the h3 pawn so there's just no
play here for black blacks down a rook
and there's no attack against White's
King soon there will be an attack
against the black King when white plays
Rick b3 or rugby one or Queen f7 yeah
that's going to be bad for black so
blacks down a rook and he's going to get
checkmated soon after g3 he resigned a
really nice win from Fabi and well it
gave him a one-and-a-half point lead
over Nakamura and well right now it's a
two-person race Caruana and so tied for
first with four out of five there's six
rounds left you guys at home know what
happened you're smarter than I am you
knew that before the broadcast but now
you know even more well I hope you
enjoyed those games I enjoyed most of
them the ones where I bet against the
guy I see here hold on a second I get
paid next week okay but maybe I can make
some more bets before it's broadcast and
I can break even this is Grandmaster
been fine go back in st. Louis I'll see
you guys twice a week for more videos
Mamba
you